well i think that america uh
for one over-indexed
on productivity
um and we consider being productive as
part of our definition of success and
the question is is it
you know i i don't think other nations
are that out of balance quite frankly
i think they have a better balance um
and i think what covid
has allowed us to do is reevaluate that
definition
um that we're kind of living like it's
the 1950s right now you know the good
parts
uh you know the we have family dinner
every night
and if you don't if you're if you and if
you're alone you're having dinner
on zoom hopefully with friends and and
uh
i find myself cooking dinner even though
i'm by myself like if i was just by
myself at home i'd have a bowl of cereal
or an egg you know i don't care
but with friends and zoom i'm finding
myself making dinner it's really nice
and so i you know i think we need to
definitely let ourselves off the
productivity hook
um you know it's it's like i said i
think we over indexed
and now we're realizing that sending
texts every moment every day and being
connected every moment every day that
it's nice not to be connected
um and to have gaps so um and in terms
of structure
i think it depends on your personality
you know some people want the structure
and need the structure then they should
build in structure
kids definitely need structure you know
um and
for people who are okay with that
structure and a little more
loosey-goosey throughout the day than
than be you but i think this whole sort
of like you know structured people
always advise structure and
non-structured people is always in no
structure and it's like
you know like whatever feels right is
the thing whatever works
[Music]
you